de nouveaux prisonniers talibans ont été
transférés vers la base américaine de
guantanamo à cuba dans le même temps
washington assouplisse sa position il
annonce que certains de ces détenus vont
être placés sous la protection de la
convention de genève
mais les états unis refusent toujours de
leur accorder le statut de prisonnier de
guerre
serge kovacs derrière ce mur de barbelés
le camp x-ray une base de l'armée
américaine ou sont interrogés nuitées
jours les talibans capturés en
afghanistan
hier soir 28 détenus sont arrivés à
guantanamo
au total 186 cas petits sont maintenant
enfermée dans cette prison de haute
sécurité les conditions de détention
vivement dénoncées par les organisations
des droits de l'homme et les
gouvernements alliés
hier l'administration bush a fini par
reconnaître à certains détenus
la protection des conventions de genève
bush a décidé aujourd'hui que la
convention de genève s'appliquerait
talibans mais pas aux terroristes
internationaux cependant les détenus
talibans n'auront pas le droit au statut
de pisany pêche
l'administration bush a donc décidé
d'opérer un tri entre les combattants du
régime taliban et les membres présumés
du réseau ben laden une distinction qui
ne change rien au traitement des détenus
parmi lesquels se trouvent au moins deux
français ni les avocats ni les
journalistes n'ont le droit de pénétrer
dans cette base militaire pour les états
unis
les prisonniers de guantanamo demeure
des hommes dangereux qui seront jugés
par des tribunaux militaires
le comité international de la croix
rouge n'est pas de cet avis pour le cicr
tous les détenus de guantanamo ont été
capturés au combat talibans ou
terroristes ils ont droit au statut de
prisonnier de guerre